のごちゃ者も当初ん
その背中のテッドでもと入るとババーンと拍手がはずですよ
ちょっと高いたかったですから私の後まだ申し上げますねちょっと頑張って
いらっしゃるん
ねじゃあ頑張って言われる話をしてくれるかと言われそうなので
しましょう
半世紀前話します
here なんと3年うち
こいつを乗せたまま
発射台でも至ったですね
というのは当時のですね宇宙船13数を使ってます
で中でまああの火災が起きた点数が止められなかった
でまあいろいろな原因究明されましたあの最近ね日本のあの瞳さんも残念な事があり
まして言及されてますけども
でまぁ当然多いですね責任のガス5回があるわけです
その時にプラグボウマン u は彼自身も中校舎ですけども彼が公聴会で行ったことが
じゃあ何が原因ですかといった時に想像力の欠如です
これねすごくいい言葉ですねまで今日の私のプレゼントといえば命を救う羅先前で唯一
ですね
想像力をテーマに歳です
で想像しください日本を離れることを
制服3000 k
掃除 masa
思う
実はだし先週ボンゴレいます
でモーグルといってもですねあの皆さんはだいたい想像するのはこの後ランダーする
だけですね
ジェニー潜るず何がどういう国か想像のためにあの
入れを教えますと年後るの国土はなんと日本の4倍ます
ところが人口はわずか300万円3000形300万円
40分の1ですね
大分想像でくださ
でその300万人のうちの
100万人がガンまずするんですん
すごいですね100万人恨まず私ブランバーンとできましたして弟でランバートのそば
でやる予定だったんですけど気付いたらここれます
スマート見下されに良い歯けどあの清覧
j これせませんなんかもうねモールが難しくで書きましたランパートの正ないヒロ
初心が版画絵ているんですねある以外 here というママちゃんですけどあの市
あの展着剤です
しかし
胸が想像される通り羊いっぱい
8尾いっぱい桜いっぱい串いっぱい甘いったりないですねそれだませんもう360度
祖母には人生が広がっていました
すごいです
これで何をやったかと言いますと
センサー天理教ですね
あの地上代打井手さんデータぐらい優雅です
上空40キロまで上がりますと気圧が200分の1になります
そうするとこの気球がパンパンに膨らむですね
decide パンク割れて落ちていく今日急なんですけどもこれは同日は日本でも
我々やっています
ただ最近ドローンとかがですね入れる不祥事やってくれたおかげで
てくれリーグであれば
まぁ実際問題やの日本で軸に落とすとなかなか番変なんですよね
今後も想像しんですけれどもページに落ちたら大変ですよねこれ
重量は6kg ですけどもドンキの馬が車のゲージに押し付けたらビッグですね
高架線にかかってこないですよね
たと言って山に落ちたら
皆さんの山ハイライトとなります
山ってねめっちゃくちゃ大変なんですよ最近飽きたとかながら動画中熊が出たいんです
けどそういう歳大変さもさることながら
ある部の対戦
しかも日本の場合は木の上にかかっちゃうとですね回収つかぬ
でどうしようかなぁと思った時に入っ
そーぞうさんですねモンゴルがれないん
ダブル広大なダイソー明星あったわけですね
the 富士山の大学では馬術部でしてあの大草原をまで走りとん
こうそういう名がちょっと良く名もあったんですけども
ボール3個でき9あげましたまあいろいろこれもですね話はなれとなるカード1泊偽派
の無事に上がりました
でマーカー付きの中に上るキヨミだから終わって良かったッ
劇中自身はですね見事40キロまで上がれましてですね
出落ちてきたっ
本編ちょっと見通しですけどこれぶーグラスですけどなんか御10杯もありますよね
じゃあこの道沿いに大衆に行けばいいじゃん思うじゃないですか
ん
そこがですね我々の想像れるのはサーカスたんですよ
我々あの想像力豊かにとか言いながらですねあの多くの人はですね反計100名たいん
だで結構するんですね
みんなそれ以外の世界で想像できない
我々も涙誘う
あ強いぐらいをとっているしてもうちょっとこんな風にちょっとで
タイプとの共演するついて日ジュっぽいイエスでこの辺までいいいいそうですけど
これ回収車で来いっ
これあのでるっていいですけどね遊牧民の住んで言ってるんですね
落ちた時の映像子にギルドについてですねえない過去に障害者男伸びますよね
これはの日本人だけでも後レジの所なんですけど
水は
今来期人口密度が少なかったらそんなねまあ牛や馬にちょっとかじられくらいからと
しか思ってないんですけど甘かったですね
島瀬渡し先ほど先生と違ってあのちゃんと数調べていくんですがたぶん家や甘い水準の
方が多いんですけども
本日はね家畜なんですねだからそれは飼っている人たちがちゃんと住んでいる
0それが例えば1数分などを買ってきた知れません100棟高200度かかっていて
それぞれを守るだけくらいに分散しているんですね
ですが行わでちょっと出てきますがいう国に強い
双眼鏡全員を持っています
家も証言的な方ができるそうです
まあで奢るをかけるはれ助かったのサービスんですけど
でこの実は割れでをあの制作元気ですねまぁいるのそばに落ちたっていうのもあるん
ですけど実はこのゲルが住民じゃなくてそこからさらに4 k ぐらい離れたこの潜る
の少年
例えば波形再生で何か向こうでピラピラしている
しかしあのたぶん10歳が10歳ぐらいのことだと思うんですけどすごい行動力ですね
4キロ圏内自分が釣り場あるんですね
目から大たらいいです
何があるん
なんかいっぱいついてる
ワッペンがログインまではこれ見たいね
やってくれましたこれあの割れ月はちょっと遅れて到着しですけど人が外に出ているだ
ミタル見るとですね
だから自在がばラバー
不実は今回の民主党はですね上空で
あの帯域地上に汚染されてない宇宙化できた生命 lives を取ろうとドイツは
本当のテーマ作成
だから上空でだけ2階てサンプルをとっておりて車に負担するという装置なんですけど
バラバラです何だしダメかですね
世界ちょっとしょんぼりするんですけどまあまあちょっと我々の想像量が足りなかった
ということで彼にはですねあの日本から持っていか鈴を上げて篤人
枚せていただいたんですがその子がね何をしてたぞ
これらくださんいますもグリスはラクダいるんですね
でこれ道路なんですよね
ブーブ思考力失禁12ちゃんとかに取ってからこれ道ね設けもにょプリウス向けも
どっち
知って地で突然なくなったりするわけですよ
どうすんだよこれ
遭難しました
俺3 t 大ではわかりますがかなり深く潜っています
でこの辺でいるはですね様はめちゃくちゃたち同様です
家畜の排せつ2波気に入ってくださいで肥料化しているそうです
で
じゃないっ
でこういうスタッフの時どうするか木切れを入れときましたね
ない
見つかった子がうちの代替コス発掘とかしたいですね
3本ぐらい6月出すけど無理です
石破ザってあります無理です
ドライ数年
って言ってから
飛ばした遊牧ちょっとベビーですがっ
愛を向こうのほうがですね馬でいい土地かじるわけでも明らかに何かちょっと変な感じ
ですけど
人が乗ってですねではパス蹴らせていただいて彼のゲルにお呼ばれし
まあまあちょっと茶でも飲んで逆ですねな南竹のヨグルトいただいて一度か気にもして
まあ何とか助かっ
でここでもう一つで問題なのは実は通信取材があればあればなんとかなんですね
なかったん
まぁ今回個人の相談を割られさげですけども
ここでちょっと話を書いて大規模災害の話だせ
今度は個人の僕の災害も置いておいて大規模災害の想像します
やられ若い分で済みますよね
そうするといつ東南海地震が空かがでしかも東南海地震の時には津波が来たんですね
そうしてこの山まで迫ったこれ道がですよ
ある意味がすぐそばにあって永妻で寸断されてしまう
パス気を呼べない
で一番違うのは
個人の相談一人ですけどまあまあなんかアホな奴がですけど草原の中で死んでるはくれ
へんかもしれんあの
助けに来てくれないけど
大規模災害の場合ですね同時に立つてに発生して所
こういう状態どういう状態なんですか
これあの若い子ですねえ3g とかも一羽様の lt 酵素快晴ですねこれあの
携帯の電話ものアンテナの受信が入るとですけどもこちら
今はつながっていますけれどもでも皆さんご存知のようにこんなアンテナがですね
中掲出シャルからなるんですね
では災害時にはこいつが全力をもくれないし聞いちゃう
全員が僕みたいに相談するわけですよね
よ残念ながら若い女に甘いませんや定額に下りる藤間選挙
た式で着てくれませんどうしますか
ようやく来て私が宇宙の人間だと皆さん理解していただきたくしませんが
そう ac があるじゃないか
それぞれです我々あのこれ gs を描いてませんから子へ子様してしてなり利用
ステーショナリー曜日といいましてですね
地球の直径一番いい選挙なりますがその3倍
離れたすごいといい36,000km 多いですねあの
静止軌道の衛星がありますこちらはすごく賢くて地球と同じ速度でもあるん
だから日本から3リリースでずっと見えてですね
だからこいつを2神明できればまあまあた好かれあう
問題があります
届い3万6千キロと糸電力も嬉しい大きなアンテナもいい
最近結構小さくなって来ないですがでもやっぱり電力がすごくてですよ
ながらが通信でき
最近はれるよう取り組んでいるのはこのエリーおーわー装備とといいですね
こいつは地球からわずか
396800よそのぐらいから最低ですねまあ政治東京駅ようなもんですよ
東京大阪間ぐらいを通信するのはそんなに大きな出る
ただしどうあそう人っていうのはこいつ1910分ですね一周ぐらいもあっているので
ずっと上にはいないですね
でしかも上に見えてるのが凄く時間が短いすぐ j せいにするよ
10分エッセ通信でい
たらこの際はどんどん数を増やすことでこれをカバーした年ですけども
で割れ今実は十津川村でやったんですけどこれこのぐらいこの大レンジパネル
1個でですねあの頃へ移設してできちゃう
石川5こっちの声小さい方ですけれどもこれあひるさんボードというのですがこれ参戦
10年の50越え wi-fi 度をボードですけど
これを使って周りの環境はいいやと計測しながらですよね
あの例えば水行ったり降ってるよとか水が行くだよとかそれをやりながら通信すると
いうこういうあゆさん坊主システムというのを組み入れてですねまぁそういう環境月を
しようということをやっております
で最近日本もっと頑張ってて
9 z 9 gs 暗号これちょっと
false 以前遂行人っていうあの中店長というんですけど
距離はですね32009年くらいだから結構遠いですが
実はこの軌道をちょっと斜めにつとばするとこんな風に8の字で衛生お徳用って起動
ですよね日本人が見つけたんですけども
これを使うとですね3期平成があると誰かは必ず真上にん
でこれ移設振動がやっぱり左翼してるんですけども
真上にある度ですね実は空気の層がちょっとしかないのでせいぜい100いるわけです
だから結構通信に通りやすいですね横だとタイプのそれがすごく暑くなるので
ものすごい電力んですけど
上田とすごいこんな10円玉ぐらいのアンテナで受信できた
でこれを今セットしてい
とするとですよ
を飲みたい地震がきましたみんなそうだしました
同9人説あれから大丈夫これあの11月に和歌山県あの内閣府の宇宙船で無粋選手と
ですね協力してあの
いろんなほい訓練します
安心だと多いでしょ
なきゃですね
だけ音何人そこで期待するのか
人に筋が全てに持っている持ってないです
でいろいろ想像しほしいんですけどあの和歌山の人はとくに若いもイメージさせるん
ですけども
まず災害起きた時にモールドと呼ばれるわけです
これ総合指揮所でまぁおそらく東南海地震が置かれればですね東京か大阪か
まぁその辺あんまりいや5個選んでないところ名古屋大阪名古屋あたりですかね
大阪にどのぐらい被害があるんですけどもそこで総合縮小があります情報は全6部に
集約されます
もう
ここのことはだけで被災触れるあまりは勘弁ですけどその下に
シルバーあくれません
それこれ私も作ってよくじゃなくてちゃんとあの災害用具なしですけど
ですレバーというのはですね要は救護所
避難所です今は災害に遭った人たちが家も潰れた
でもここに来ると皆水 rc 分関係してもいるよ
これが多分かなりの数そういうこと50カ所が8か所
できるんですねで実は先ほどの準天頂衛星の通信機はここに置かれます
だからここは通信に途切れません
どうですね災害時みんなここ式陥らないけど一番たいのはどこか
100球の私のあのそうなゲームを目指しくださいあそこです
これブロンズといいですね
ミョンズっていうのはもうまさに埋まっています流されてばスマホ
あと少しで死んじゃいますこんな場所これが山のようにあるここが一番問題
ここからここにどうやってくるようですあの頃添い寝ほっといてもあまりしません
ここが本当に住んじゃうけどの女信者かというと
足ませんか球ごと急なが違うということは同盟都市ですけどちょ
近衛な枚下がったですがそろそろ時間をつけようとしますが
実はあの72時間以内で助けないとほとんど死んだよーって言っているのはこの
まさにこの柔軟別のゲームのしたいです
愛のせずどんどんしていきますでも311の時は実は自衛隊の d マートの開脚冤罪
も48時間までに全て到着していました
じゃ90%自衛隊に助けられたかパスからなんですね
7たかというとこれが西一条時の救出
住む水です
もうはツールバーには状が来たらばっ
自衛隊終盤までいったでもブロンズの情報が来てないん
だからこれじゃあ何しなかったがまくっ
りすかいも4810月に72回すぎるでもほとんど死んじゃう家ですよ
だからも自衛隊の現場指揮官がですね柔軟言葉使える子痛い笑ってあげてくださいです
綺麗でを回タップですね
被害のなにもんでも
これはどうすればいいかと言うところ簡単な子で
生きてるんですからこれをぽっちに移せばいいですね
こういう救出はこの到着分台から買える可能なんです
ところがこれをやるためには撥水してくらい24時間は皆さんたブロンズに最終るん
です
でシルバーに行ってくれるステージですその人たちが情報をシルバーに集めてゴールに
流さないとこれは実現できない
この丸い言うとそうかと思うかも知れませんでそれをやるための方法
実はこれ55倍くらいでこれだけの情報サイ教えてくれです
どこで誰がどうなってどんな状況か
これは私にはやりたいと思い頑張ったんですかなかなかできないですねそれで責任どう
するとか
やってダメが薄めたら知らないものとかですねそれがいまの現状
最後は私が言いたいのですね
紀伊半島沖ます5年以内ぐらいに行きますと長いです
その時によく日本のとか世界のは日までは良いことがいいんですけどそれはいいんです
そんなことに割れやらなきゃいけないのは
批判との岡山の翼として今言ったようなブロンズからゴールドシルバーに同情報グルか
ここですね1で影だけ
デブですいません最後そこで真面目な子になっちまいましたがあの頃本来答えないです
で結構いろんなそこ話をしましたがこれはできへんでと言われている
理事長店で技術書いちゃってきましたけれどもこのままじゃ
のでが全然意味がないが多いですだからぜひ今日集まった人たち
あの連でくださいそれでこうした凛ちゃんを明日リーチャーをですね
このやっぱり地元代表して考えたいと思いますどうもありがとうございます